alors il vend sa schtroumpfs je vous
vois déjà bien fait quoi depuis la
dernière fois qu'on s'est trompé et on
sait le trophée ou la dernière fois
qu'on s'est fait au bistrot au bistrot
j'ai retrouvé un travail sur les rosiers
et alors vous avez stroumpfs explique
bert quand même je pense que c'est pas
fini je vais retrouver avec lui pour
pense que ça va je suis sûr j'ai
retrouvé a expliqué un arrêt ouais ben
c'est bien parce qu'il est assez
schtroumps comme réalisateur et le grand
élément aussi il
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux
schtroumpfs qui disent que finalement ce
film est assez je trouve ils ont ils se
trouvent très local y est alors je
voudrais en bleu c'est très ami avec le
recul vous la schtroumpf et comment
votre carrière il vend bien ou pas bien
les schtroumpfs assez bien ouais oui ça
dépend des fois j'ai stroumpfs oh ça
dépend il se trouve exactement ça dépend
des schtroumpfs td c'est le mot qui
cherche un nom mais souhaite écrire aux
eskimos schtroumpfs et quand vous vous
seront faits dans une glace quand je me
retrouve dans la glace je me retrouve
mara et vous trouverez vos cheveux non
je ne trouve pas mes cheveux et non je
ne trouve pas mon beau merci
et est-ce que plus jeune vous êtes déjà
schtroumpfer dans un lit avec deux jeux
tron fait
ouais avec de jeu trouble fête en bac 2
sommes pas des schtroumpfs est très très
drôle
est ce que vous trouvez pet de consoles
de temps pas tant que ça à mon nom je
suis pas triste room biker et charlotte
plus que moi alors je trouverai bien
charlotte 7e rang je trouve toi de toi
est elle totalement si je bois un petit
peu je peux je trouve peine mais sans ça
je suis pas très content des gens chez
eux et la redevance que c'est un
scandale je public
oui bah il vous remercie vous retrouvez
fait quand vous voulez merci beaucoup